tulsi gabbard joins me now tulsi it's
always
great to see you there is something very
bizarre going on in america
uh right now normally the ship estate is
very hard to stare it's like the titanic
yet in nothing flat all our key agencies
in the so-called intelligence community
have turned on a dime and decided that
the biggest
threat to america is domestic extremism
whatever that is
i think whatever that is is exactly the
glaring problem with this mark is that
as this new campaign and focus on
against
you know white supremacists racist
domestic domestic
extremists uh is is launched none of
these terms are very clearly
defined or really defined at all if you
look at at the term white supremacists
for example i think this is something
that
that many would agree has been clearly
clearly established as
you know the philosophy of the kkk and
and nazis is people who believe hey the
white race is superior and therefore
must
have power and control over all other
races
but we live in a world now where we have
people in power who say
if you're white you're a white
supremacist whether you know it or not
if you're white
you're a racist whether you know it or
not and if you follow that approach
that means that any white person in
america
could be the target of surveillance if
you look at okay well what is domestic
extremism
uh is is being extremely patriotic
being a domestic extremist you know if
you look at our service members and our
veterans who have been targeted and
pointed out by those in our government
as being vulnerable to
being domestic extremists well i've
served with
incredible great patriots as a veteran
and soldier
myself people who are willing to lay
their lives down and
die for this great country
that we love is this who they're talking
about when when they're saying
that we need to look out for domestic
extremists it's
absolutely outrageous and it's offensive
it's offensive to those who i've served
with
including those who have paid the
ultimate price
and given their lives in service to our
country
uh this is the danger of of the
direction where we seem to be headed in
the fact that these terms these
these broad targets that they're
pointing out really are not being
clearly defined at all isn't it also the
opposite of what you do
if you have a real terrorism movement
because the the object of terrorism is
to terrorize
so as after 9 11 uh the president and
the government said
don't be terrorized go about your normal
lives now the government
actually seems to be trying to get
hundreds of millions of americans
uh worked up over a domestic terror
threat that doesn't actually exist
the the direction that they're taking is
is not only dangerous
in how broad and vague it is it's
dangerous in the threat that it poses
to our constitution and our
constitutional rights
you know you mentioned 911 and you
looked at these broad far-reaching laws
like the patriot act
that were passed uh you know the secret
fisa court and we've seen now for almost
20 years how those authorities have
infringed on our civil liberties
and our constitutional rights and
instead of doing the right thing in our
government and in congress democrats and
republicans are both responsible for
this
doing the right thing and saying hey
let's let's get rid of those things so
that we are actually upholding our
constitution
instead of doing that in the wake of
january 6. you have democrats and
republicans saying you know what
what we need is to pass more laws that
further infringe on our civil liberties
that further allow for mass surveillance
uh on on americans and so this points to
exactly the wrong direction
that our leaders in our country are
dangerously headed
we were told back when all that stuff
started that
all we'll be don't worry about uh your
cell phone
it's so we can eavesdrop on some guy
sitting in a cave
in waziristan who wants to get up to
something and he's
sitting in his cave plotting it on his
cell phone uh they're quite
open now about turning these tools
these very sophisticated tools on the
most lavishly funded agencies on earth
on their own citizens and
and not only doing so uh through our own
government agencies
but also looking to these big social
media tech
giants uh you know whether it's it's
facebook or google or youtube
or others to essentially act as as
proxies
and you've seen in some of the reports
that have come out recently that our
national security apparatus is directly
working with these social media giants
uh to further encroach upon our civil
liberties upon our privacy
and to further surveil the actions
activities words
thoughts political affiliations or or or
what not
of everyday americans across the country
and and uh again
moving in in a very dangerous direction
that flies in the face of
our constitution and that this is being
done by leaders in our government
who have taken an oath to uphold and
protect
our constitution makes it even more
treacherous
are you concerned about uh
the politicization let me put it as
mildly as i can
of something even as routine as
a medical examiner's office i mean it
seems to me
uh somewhat unlikely that three months
on that uh they cannot state
what officer sicknick died of and it
also seems
odd to me and again disturbingly
politicized that we have no idea at the
same time as a policeman
is on trial in minneapolis we have no
idea of
who shot an unarmed woman in the united
states capital these facts are known to
the authorities
but for some reason uh the the people of
the united states aren't allowed to be
privy to them
this this issue of politicizing our
government institutions at a very basic
level
is one of the reasons why the vast you
know so many americans
uh have lost faith and trust in these
institutions because they've seen
how they are used essentially as
political tools or weapons to serve one
side
or the other this is also directly
linked to
the issue we started this conversation
with which is
if you have these vague terms that
really can be
applied to a very large swath of people
that can change depending on who's in
power so who is a domestic extremist
really
at this point then it becomes well it
becomes defined by whoever's in power
and who
they choose to use our institutions
to target absolutely chelsea that's one
of the most
weaselly words of all uh extremists
great to see you tonight
uh really appreciate your input also